hola 42 aki today's video is kindly
sponsored by babel
the number one language learning gap in
the world
hey 42 here if you were to walk through
salem massachusetts today
you'd find a pleasant commuter town by
the sea
its leafy streets are lined with
traditional weatherboard houses
and ships bob on the waves in its
peaceful harbour
however you'd also find a string of
wiccan
and pagan shops with names such as the
cauldron black
and covens cottage where you can buy
spell books
crystals and even broomsticks visited
halloween
and you'll find the entire town has been
taken over by
tourists in terrifyingly silly costumes
salem's name will always be inextricably
linked with the 17th century witch
trials
that took place there in 1692
and 93 around 200 people in salem
and the surrounding villages were
accused of witchcraft and
tried in court 30 people were found
guilty
14 women and five men were hanged
curiously two dogs were also executed
i suppose when your dog begins
levitating whilst chitting on your
carpet
it's time to put it down the accusations
began
when it was suspected that two local
girls had been possessed by the devil
betty paris aged 9 the daughter of a
local puritan church minister
and abigail williams 11 her orphaned
cousin who lived with the family the
girls seemed to be behaving
in rather strange ways they had fits
screamed in pain and through things
they were found in strange contortions
on the ground
and regularly hid under the furniture
they even barked like dogs with over 10
million subscribers worldwide
and new content daily it's easy to see
why babble is top of the list for anyone
wishing to learn
and develop a new language for me
it was about taking a short break from
my daily routine
and flexing those cognitive muscles a
little bit in a productive and
fun way with the goal of improving my
holiday vocabulary
i'm using babble to learn to speak
french
before babel i couldn't even order a
croissant in france
and i wish i was joking but now
i can have meaningful human
conversations when abroad
it has genuinely changed the way i
travel
babble is packed full of content
designed by language experts
it offers 10 to 15 minute short and fun
classes
that are proven to get you speaking in a
new language
in just three weeks there's also loads
of new podcasts
stories and games to fully immerse
yourself
in the language of your choice so if
you're looking to become bilingual for
professional reasons
or you just feel like learning a new
language would be
a great personal achievement for you
then i would highly recommend
trying babble and you can take advantage
of six months for free
when you sign up for six months all you
need to do is click the link in the
description
below as a religious man reverend
paris's first reaction
was to pray for his daughter and niece
and their souls
but all the praying in the world didn't
stop them from doing gymnastics onto the
coffee table
so the minister quickly realized he
needed backup
a doctor and another minister named john
hale
were summoned to the house to examine
the girls and
the rather odd happenings shocked by
what he found
reverend hale reported these children
were bitten
and pinched by invisible agents their
arms
necks and backs turned this way and that
way
and returned back again so it was
impossible for them to do
of themselves strange stuff indeed
and those present immediately pegged the
blame
on witchcraft what other explanation
could a 17th century puritan minister
find for his daughter
writhing on the floor and barking sheer
blister-inducing boredom perhaps
the girls were known to have been
experimenting with the bizarre practice
of umancy shortly before all the fitting
and driving malarkey
umancy was attempting to predict the
future using a separated
uncooked egg and a mirror used by the
ancient greeks and vikings
umanci had become something of an
illicit craze in 17th century
massachusetts
and the girls were thought to have been
attempting to conjure a vision
of their future husbands using it but
instead of seeing a lovely vision of
brad pitt one of the girls
saw a coffin an omen of what was to come
perhaps whether the mystic eggs had
anything to do with it or not
once the word witchcraft had been
uttered it didn't take long for
accusations to
fly around salem the first to be accused
of afflicting the girls was tituba
the family's living slave then
accusations were hurled at sarah good
a poverty-stricken homeless woman who
begged in the local streets
and a similarly poor elderly woman sarah
osborne
all three were powerless to defend
themselves without social standing
or money for women like them an
accusation of witchcraft would prove
fatal
so it was strange then that when
tried tituba decided to give the court
exactly what it wanted to hear perhaps
she was delirious
or maybe she was trying to save herself
from the executioner's noose
but over the course of three days she
told a lord tale
in which she recounted seeing a man in
black who'd forced her
to sign her name in the devil's book
making her
the devil's servant she then said sarah
good
sarah osborne and six unnamed others had
done the same she also told of seeing
sarah good send yellow birds to attack
the two girls
and the cat to attack and scratch
another girl
her damning confession gave tituba the
nickname
the black witch of salem amongst the
community
with such bizarre tall tales flying
around the
town salem began to descend into a
vicious whirlwind of collective
madness which lasted for over a year
more people came forward accusing anyone
they didn't quite fancy the look of
of being a witch husbands even accused
their wives
siblings turned on each other lifelong
friends
became enemies even children didn't
escape
the youngest person to be accused and
arrested was the five-year-old daughter
of sarah goode
a little girl named dorothy dorothy was
eventually released
but her mother was hanged of course not
everyone in salem relished the trials
and the disintegration of their town
into a madness of accusations and
executions but those who did oppose
weren't exactly able to say so
only a very brave or very foolish person
would have stuck her neck out into the
salem witch trial fray
as doing so would probably just see her
accused of witchcraft too
the whole thing was turning into one big
witch pursuit
thing even when there was clear room for
doubt
no one in salem dared voice it amply
illustrated by the sad story of george
burrows
who was accused of being the witch's
ring leader
despite being a church minister in salem
it wasn't enough to save him but it did
mean that standing on the gallows in the
last moments of his life
he gave the watching crowd a word
perfect recitation
of the lord's prayer this it was thought
would have been an impossible task for a
witch
because witches simply could not pray
they still hanged him anyway well they
had gone to a lot of effort to get
everything
set up when a citizen was accused of
witchcraft
she could plead guilty or innocent it
may surprise you that the majority
pleaded guilty yes they said i'm guilty
of being an actual witch you may be
somewhat less surprised however when i
tell you that a guilty plea
usually resulted in jail time whereas
an innocent play would almost always
result in execution
why well puritans believed that lying
was a sin
and since the town had already
unanimously decided the accused was
probably a witch before the trial if she
did plead innocent
she just had to be lying and therefore
had committed
another sin on top of being a bleeding
witch
for which she obviously deserved to now
die
a guilty plea however demonstrated
remorse
and repentance good traits according to
the puritan ideal
and therefore the accused would usually
be spared
not all who pleaded innocent were
however and many
met the hangman's noose located at the
now
infamous gallows hill regardless
contrary to
some pop culture depictions not a single
witch was burnt at the stake during the
salem witch trials
that was how the europeans back home
like to do it though there was the odd
exception of giles corey a farmer in
salem who was accused of being a witch
by the community
and was executed by being slowly crushed
to death
under large stones so how
does a sleepy new england colonial town
take leave of its senses and start
hanging their satanic neighbours
left right and center to really
understand the salem witch trials
we need to take a look at what life was
like in 17th century salem and the
surrounding villages and farmsteads
the colony had only been established six
decades earlier in 1626
and even at the time of the witch trials
many of those who lived in salem would
have been
recent arrivals mostly from england who
traveled to the new colony
in order to enjoy religious freedom
specifically
puritanism a movement that practiced
protestantism
in its purest form and sure
they found purity in new england but
they also found fear the colony was
surrounded by the ocean
on one side and wilderness on all of us
the little lore and order there was
struggled to contain the constant
infighting
and power grabs between the colonists
and
there was the ever looming threat of
attack from native americans
in fact only a decade before the witch
trials in 1676
a brutal 15-year war between the
settlers and the local population
had just come to a bloody end it killed
one out of every 10 of the colonies
adult men
and destroyed numerous homes and
businesses
so it's fair to say in 1692
the residents of salem weren't enjoying
a peaceful life
but one in which fear and suspicion
was around every corner every sunday
they would stand in church to hear a
puritan sermon
that spoke vividly of the devil and the
dangers that lay beyond the walls of
their homes
and the fences of their farms for most
salem residents
the only respite from their arduous
existence
was to be found in the bible they would
gather around a warm fire
at the end of a long day to share
stories of the devil
witchcraft and holy reverence and so
the entire population was ripe for
suggestion
and when the first accusations of
sorcery began to fly
it isn't difficult to understand why it
spread through the colony
like an epidemic of suspicion some have
sought alternative explanations for
salem's sudden descent into madness
diseases such as epilepsy and lyme
disease have been blamed
but there's little evidence for either
more plausible
is the idea that a hallucinogenic fungus
could be to blame the ergot fungus grows
on grains such as rye and wheat
which just so happen to have been
staples of the salem diet
it causes sickness fits and
hallucinations
which sounds remarkably similar to the
behavior exhibited by
betty paris abigail williams and others
but even this theory as neat as it
sounds
is unlikely unless most of europe and
north america
spent about 300 years high on ergot
because salem wasn't unique wits trials
many of them much bigger and deadlier
than salem's
had been commonplace across europe for
hundreds of years
it's hardly surprising then given the
traditions back home
that colonists began killing so-called
witches
almost as soon as they arrived in the
new world if we go back to 1626
one of the very first north american
witch trials
took place in the jamestown colony in
virginia
the courts there heard that a midwife
named joan
wright had carried out multiple acts of
witchcraft
against the people of the town these
included
bewitching chickens and butter churns
killing a baby forcing a girl to dance
naked
and causing heavy rain that destroyed a
tobacco farmer's crops
which sounds like a regular friday night
from where i come from
there's no record of jones fate but the
virginia courts were slightly more
lenient
on spooky behavior than those in
massachusetts
so it's likely she was spared those
accused of witchcraft
in connecticut however were not so lucky
around 40 people are thought to have
been tried in the states in the second
half of the 17th century
11 of whom were executed such as mary
johnson
who confessed after torture to
familiarity with the devil
but to be fair i think i'd curse the
devil a few times as someone had a
castle brand
pressed to my nipples the others
fortunate enough to escape
fled for their lives into the american
wilderness
over in europe the worst of the
witchcraft trials were over by the time
salem's took place in 1692
however it's fought an astonishing 50
000 people most of them women were
executed for witchcraft
in europe between 1400 and 1782
when the final european witch trial and
execution took place
in switzerland the peak of the european
wits trial craze
was in the early 17th century however
and
it got pretty out of hand germany in
particular
loved a good witch bothering with mass
executions taking place on several
occasions most horrific were the
wurzburg witch trials
between 1626 and 1631.
around 200 people some of them children
were beheaded
and burnt at the stake in the town
center
in england the 1612 pendlewitch trial
is kind of like the british salem as
in salem the trial started as a result
of an accusation
which spiraled out of control a woman
refused to buy some pins
from a street hawker who shortly
afterwards
no doubt coincidentally collapsed and
was taken to a local pub
there he accused a woman of witchcraft
the investigation saw many pendle
families being interviewed
and accusations ripped through the town
the result
was 12 alleged witches were tried in
lancaster castle
10 of whom were hanged what's kind of
funny about witch trials
is that for hundreds of years witches
were considered a helpful component
of conventional society throughout the
middle ages
people visited their local witch to buy
a potion or a spell
a love struck young man would procure a
love potion
an elderly woman would ask for a potion
to save her ailing husband from his sick
bed
a farmer might ask the witch to help
find his missing sheep
the catholic church wasn't particularly
bothered about witches
they were too preoccupied with heaven
armies and endless crusades
but with the spread of protestantism
came a new
found fear and hatred of witchcraft and
generally suspicious female behavior
martin luther
kind of set the tone for the movement
when he personally authorized the
execution
of at least four witches as
protestantism grew
so the catholic church decided they had
better upped their
witch-pursuiting game too so
when puritan settlers left a religiously
divided europe behind
to seek new religious freedom in new
england
it's no wonder that witchcraft was top
of their minds when it came to
establishing
a legal code the first crime punishable
by death in new england
was worshiping idols viewed by puritans
as a dangerous
catholic practice the second was
witchcraft
with the text if any man or woman be a
witch
that is has or consult with a familiar
spirit
they shall be put to death added to the
massachusetts law books
murder only features fourth on the list
after blasphemy
jesus christ i better be careful not to
murder anyone
but the people of salem were not
completely without reason
just as doubt had crept in when george
burrows recited the lord's prayer from
the gallows
so it continued to spread through the
town in the years after the trials
petitions were filed in 1700 for free
women who'd been convicted
but not yet executed and all three
were pardoned by the court and relatives
of previously executed victims were also
granted compensation
finally in 2001 after 300 years
massachusetts legally exonerated
every person who'd been convicted at
salem
because in 2000 they were obviously
still trying to figure out if magic is
actually real
thanks for watching